so there's a guy standing in a storm
and this has gone viral image of
Kellogg's worker picketing in 3 A.M
storm goes viral well this these are the
things I don't this is like when you
find a kid you know the Drone strike
they show the kid and the Drone strike
and they go this is why we have to fight
Isis because and you go what
um I do like the Tony the Tiger I'm
greedy sign it is fun because you know
what you can do here with the strike and
people lose you can have a lot of fun
with the mascots you can have a lot of
fun with the mascots like there should
be a mini wheat with the the hammer and
sickle you know the Communist hammer and
sickle there should be a mini wheat
doing that dress up a mini weed is
Joseph Stalin
if they're not dressing up Mini Wheats
as Joseph Stalin
the rice crispy
what are they elves the rice crispy
elves should be
uh
they should be painted
uh killing Executives like cutting the
throats of executives
the Fruit Loops toucan toucan Sam
Toucan Sam should have his arm around
Mao Zedong
this is fun this is good this gets
people thinking because you start going
oh this is interesting even the mascots
are getting involved a lot of the
problem is I don't care about any of
those people right you know the people
with the signs who gives a [ __ ] I don't
know them but if all the mascots got
together the son Tony the Tiger those
twinks who make rice crispy treats uh
and the Corn Flakes uh chicken if they
own a rooster he's a rooster whatever
his gender is none of my business if
they all got together and explicitly if
there was artwork of them killing
Executives burning their houses down
you know that to me would be a little
exciting I'd want to get more on board
yes you know get a picture of Joseph
staliner
get a picture of Stalin now let's
imagine get a get a nice picture Okay of
of uh Stalin I like this one this one's
good
make that make give the Raisin Bran Sun
put the raisin brand Sun as Stalin